I don't I don't want to give anything
away he may or may not be in the movie
Harry Potter franchise fans Johnny Depp
is starring in the fantastic beasts and
where to find them movies and now we
know what role he will play director
David Yates revealed the news in an
interview with the leaky cauldron we are
warning you now spoilers ahead how did
you react when you found out he was
gonna be and I found out when the world
found out so Depp will play the evil
wizard
Gellert Grindelwald this will be the
characters first appearance in any of
the Wizarding World movies the cast told
us most of them did not film with him
seemingly only Eddie Redmayne new depths
true a purpose what was it like working
with him
well I didn't get to work with him so
was it was something that existed
completely separate from me so you guys
did not know no I was physically not
there I did know when we came to shoot
at that moment
Eddie show us more than Eddie knows a
little bit more than arrest gates also
confirmed fans will see a young Albus
Dumbledore at some point in the five
fantastic beasts films that was
something we'd gotten hints of what
character are you guys most excited to
see or encounter in the next movie
oh I hope to encounter I hope to
encounter a young a grid' I don't know
what's going to happen but obviously you
know the idea of meeting a young
Dumbledore would be incredible just to
see how he evolved because he's such an
incredibly wise
man
you